I don't know how to explain it I'm more  just baffled that's not a bigger story I  it's just it's mind-blowing to me I  don't want him to lose his job or get  fired but there should be some  repercussions to hit in your life  here's a question I'd say I don't know  the uprise did come eventually and and  the people get a hold of it because  remember Dana is pretty Dana's boys with  Trump  super boys of Trump trump supporter uh  refuse vaccines lockdowns he's he's that  far right guy he's a far-right guy right  I can't believe the left hasn't got a  hold of this  I just went bananas on it  that  how powerful he is even laugh was like  um  but you're gonna [ __ ] with Elon Musk and  Trump and Trump like all these powerful  people but Dana's where you draw the  line holy [ __ ] I might go missing after  this podcast